greetings from podcastville
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
on it from alpha brain to new mood
to shroom tech and it's got you covered
do me a favor for today go to honor.com
right now i mean listen
times are tough health is tough but you
gotta take care of yourself
go to honor.com right now take a look at
the selection of what they got i did a
video
that came out today on instagram talking
about the melatonin
and the new mood i mean alpha brain is
fantastic
the shroom tech is fantastic the protein
powder is fantastic
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for go to
honey.com right now
and put in code church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your first order
from uncle joey how's that for you the
second thing i want to talk to you is
about
c b d lion from vapor pens to cbd
patches to bath balls
to tinctures to rub to the cream
cbd lion has you [ __ ] covered okay
what i want you to do is go if you're
concerned about cbd
go to cbdlion.com right now and take a
look
read read about cbn cbd
the effects what works for you this will
make your life a lot easier
whether you have pain whether you have
insomnia
whether you have anxiety this will help
do you understand me so do me a favor go
to cbdline.com right now
take a look at the selection of their
cbd products and again
read read
don't go to some [ __ ] liquor store
and buy it or some guy named pepe
and nothing happens to you okay so knock
it off
cbdline.com
now let the [ __ ] podcast
begin candles are lit
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
welcome to uncle joey's joint i know
this is not what you expected you
expected glamour
and dancing girls and [ __ ] lighting
their [ __ ] with firecrackers and [ __ ]
but that's not it today today we're
going for bad [ __ ] bones okay
what i mean with bad bones is
everything's on order
for some reason this [ __ ] covert put
everything the cameras can't get here
the ipad can't get here the electrician
couldn't come for two weeks
so i said [ __ ] it i know you guys need
the podcast you need somebody to talk to
you've been sitting there going joey
where the [ __ ] you've been for starters
i've been working the plan i had a plan
from day one and i'm happy
i [ __ ] stuck to it because i was a
[ __ ] mess
okay the anxiety started hitting me in
la
then i down down a little bit when i
knew i was gonna move
but once i did do the move it caught on
fire like those [ __ ] fires in
california
it did not stop uh once i moved in
and got settled i started working the
steps like i told you
the first move was just to get out of
california the second move was just to
decompress
i'm very happy i spent those 10 days in
corporate housing they i was [ __ ]
bricks i ain't gonna lie to you i
thought i
made a mistake i was double thinking
myself which all of us do
you know we all put our pants on the
same [ __ ] leg
at a time so i was you know i
i didn't mind moving it wasn't me it was
that i was taking
my daughter and my wife and i didn't
know i was gonna affect them
but those 10 days in corporate housing
over in middle new jersey there were the
best 10 days of my life all we did was
walk
and [ __ ] barbecue and [ __ ] swim
uh i went to see my friends maybe two
times during those ten days
but that was all i did was just to get
the la stink off me
just to get the malouka eye off me how
to kill a couple [ __ ] chickens
santoria style i had how to do what i
had to do
just to get that la [ __ ] dirt off me
then we moved into the house august 31st
and then we had a [ __ ] uh wait for
the furniture till the fourth
so for four days we slept on [ __ ]
hand mattresses
i needed a nike pack an acupuncturist
and 22 [ __ ] chiropractors every
[ __ ] morning okay
it was close to the floor it was a
[ __ ] nightmare but we did it
then school started it's only going two
days a week
but those monday and tuesday i got her
in school
all the only two days i got to run
that's it the rest of the time
i gotta share with my wife i can't put
all the burden on my wife you dig
number three now they're going to school
four days a week
on the 19th and that gives me more time
to hang out with you [ __ ]
but that was the plan i didn't want to
get off a plane
and jump right into the [ __ ] fire my
head wasn't even involved in it i
couldn't even [ __ ] focus on anything
thank god thank god for [ __ ] alpha
brain thank god
for notebooks thank god for walks
thank god for friends you know it
started with one friend
and two friends would get together and
three friends
and i felt comfortable again you know
the news destroyed me in la
i have not turned down the news one time
i don't know nothing about nothing and
guess what
i don't want to know it's got nothing to
do with me i'm not a member of the
republican party
the democratic party i'm a member of the
felon party so
that means they ain't got nothing to do
they don't [ __ ] even consider me
people ask me you're gonna vote
mike tyson is voting i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't want nothing to do with nothing
all i want to do is do podcasts
smoke reefer and be a father to my
daughter that's it
you're asking me joey where's the reefer
there ain't no reefer
this is my [ __ ] house i can't be
smoking reefer with a seven-year-old
upstairs
she's on the play date that's why i'm
down here yelling and screaming
that's the other problem i have my
office is in my [ __ ] house
so i can't be lighting fires and [ __ ]
going off and
torturing [ __ ] but i worked to
plan
and that's what i was trying to say to
you then after that i shot the movie
out of quarantine i i listen i really
wanted to shoot this movie
if i tested positive i wouldn't be able
to shoot the [ __ ] movie
so i tried to do everything i can in my
power
just to stay clean mass washing my hands
not that much contact boom my
sister-in-law dies
i gotta drive to [ __ ] delaware which
is a hot state as it is
you get [ __ ] covered just picking up
a piece of paper in [ __ ] delaware
i had to go to a funeral parlor wearing
a mask so i thought i was a ghana right
off the bat
i want to give condolences to my family
my sister-in-law and i hope she's
resting in peace
and having where she belongs but beside
that
i thought i was a ghana then i went to a
family reunion and there was a ton of
[ __ ] people that
people hadn't seen in years i tried to
wear a mask as much as i can
when people are drinking there ain't no
social distancing i wasn't drinking
i was freaking out on the [ __ ] edible
i had seen people
i saw people i hadn't seen in 30 [ __ ]
years the edibles scrambled my [ __ ]
mind
when i saw these people i dug into
myself i got very insulated
finally towards the end is when my old
self came back and i started enjoying
myself
and it was a big mistake and not only
did i eat the edibles i gave them to my
[ __ ] family members they were all
[ __ ] up too
i got a brother that just disappeared
for like six hours
then they came out of a bush i'm like
what the [ __ ] of you biggest man what'd
you give me
i gave them those atx tablets those 200
milligrams
those things aren't [ __ ] around jack
you eat two of those
they'll put you on a bus with kids with
[ __ ] helmets and special needs
they ain't [ __ ] around you know what
i'm saying those things are real
i'm not offending nobody here with
special needs i got my own problems
too my grandparents are second cousins
if anybody's [ __ ] it's me so i got
the right to talk about retards or
or [ __ ] half breeze whatever the [ __ ]
they are i got a ton of [ __ ] problems of
my own
i don't need no aggravation that's the
other thing i'm not [ __ ] cleaning up
my act i don't give a [ __ ]
it's 2020. if you get [ __ ] uh
you know sensitized or whatever that's
not my problem that's your [ __ ]
problem
that's your [ __ ] problem i'm a
student i'm a student of the [ __ ] 70s
i'm an old [ __ ] man
and i'm not [ __ ] getting [ __ ] uh i
don't even know what the word is for you
[ __ ] people that's not gonna happen
you either take me as i come or go [ __ ]
yourself
i'm not gonna [ __ ] change for you
people because your feelings get
home because we're going to walk out who
gives a [ __ ] walk out [ __ ]
how is it how does it feel when you
don't got no insurance you blew head
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying we're going to
walk out because what the [ __ ] is wrong
with people
get your [ __ ] life together you're
getting paid
shut the [ __ ] up put earphones on you
don't like what the man says put your
phones on
the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
offended
you're gonna walk out walk out [ __ ]
it's a tough [ __ ] world
out there trying to get insurance where
do you get that [ __ ] covert bill
so you better listen you better shut
your [ __ ] mouth
and you [ __ ] don't let that listen do
what i do change the channel
you know you've been stuck in a hotel
room and telemundo's on
and you can't find a remote control you
rather jump out the [ __ ] window
change the [ __ ] channel that's it
that's why we're here anyway back to the
[ __ ] story
i did the soprano movie i'm [ __ ]
ecstatic it's over
that gave me a bunch of [ __ ]
tremendous boost of confidence because
that's what i needed
i need to get my [ __ ] confidence back
and then we moved in and i'm like where
are we gonna do the podcast
so i divided three different [ __ ]
rooms for you people i've dedicated
three [ __ ] rooms it's gonna be a cold
winter
you want content i'm gonna give you some
[ __ ] content okay
i'm gonna give you all the content i put
except porn uncle joey's too old to be
doing porn
my dick is shrunked up it's getting old
it smells funny
nobody wants to do porn with an old man
as much as you people like to see it no
porn here
but i'm gonna shoot [ __ ] content as
much as i can
on patreon we're going to do a record of
the week i can't do it on youtube
you get flagged and they want to throw
you under the [ __ ] jail so i got to
do it on patreon the patreon tiers are 3
5 10 and fifteen dollars starting
october 12th we're gonna switch it all
around
everybody gets a [ __ ] bargain okay
you do what the [ __ ] you want to do
i'm not forcing you putting a gun to
your head or nothing
so after the movie what was the next
step the next step was getting on stage
and i did that two weeks ago with rich
voss
and my dear friend jimmy florentine and
my dear friend rich voss
they invited me to do an outdoor thing
for uncle vinnie's
i got there it was a [ __ ] parking lot
people had chairs let me tell you what
my biggest fear was guys i wasn't scared
of bombing
i bombed before if you're [ __ ] afraid
of bombing
don't don't don't get involved in this
[ __ ] you got a bomb
i wasn't scared about bombing the stage
was up against the wilderness
like there was a [ __ ] wilderness a
couple comics went up before me i'm
sitting there going what the [ __ ]
the biggest fear i have is that a bear
is going to come out
and drag me into the [ __ ] woods so
now i'm on stage
and i'm feeling like one of those facts
from vegas remember that dude
the street field lloyd whatever the
[ __ ] name is
the tiger came out and ripped his
[ __ ] leg off that's what i
i'm on stage trying to tell jokes and
all i'm thinking about is a [ __ ] bear
coming out and grabbing me and [ __ ]
i called rich voss the next day to go
rich you know thank you for the gig
dog for a minute there i was [ __ ]
scared i thought i was gonna [ __ ] get
attacked by a bag you're lucky you
didn't come to the gig two weeks ago
he goes there was flying squirrels and
bats he goes i had to put my
hood on or a bat would get stuck in my
head that's it
once he said bat that said i ain't doing
no outdoor gigs but
i am doing every wednesday the month of
october at vinnie's
just to get my [ __ ] feet back on the
ground just to
so if you want to come down i only see
36 people so it's a small crowd
it's spaced hopefully you won't get
covered i'm not looking to get kovid
i don't want you to get covered i want
you to be healthy so you can feed your
families
and you can have a great thanksgiving
and a great christmas i don't give a
[ __ ]
about this covered [ __ ] all right you
got to live your life put the mask on
wash your hands don't finger bang nobody
not supposed to
you see some chick thing of me for two
dollars you don't want to finger that
there's covert in that [ __ ] hole
don't touch that [ __ ] and try your best
that's all you can
and if you do get it let me tell you
something you're not gonna punch the
[ __ ] ticket
if you're mutated so much now that
you're gonna get sick my heart goes out
to the president my heart goes out to
cam
newton my heart goes out to anybody
who's gotten this [ __ ] rotten disease
because you don't need the aggravation
it's been scary
and it's been a it's been a heavy toll
on people you know i guarantee you
that they they got to tell you how many
people have died of a heart attack you
know what let me tell you something
the only reason why i haven't died of a
heart attack is because i got to have
keith richards as the odd one heart
that cocaine heart that [ __ ] that that
had to help me number two i walked the
hills of northberg
as a kid i've been going to north bergen
once a week lately
just once a week that's all you need in
my hometown and when i drive those hills
i look at them and i go i cannot [ __ ]
believe
i used to walk up these [ __ ] hills
backwards backwards because the wind was
blowing
and you didn't want the wind hitting
your face i would walk up those hills
with a bottle of vodka and gatorade in
one hand you understand me that's how
much
how good i was so my fat little heart
couldn't
the 21st of august i had an anxiety
attack so [ __ ] bad
that i had to go lay down with my
daughter watch cartoons
because i thought i was going to die i
might as well die in her bed
she was watching like big city greens or
something my heart
beat so hard on the 21st because i
thought i made a mistake
that my chest hurt for the rest
of the [ __ ] weekend that's how high
my anxiety and my stress levels were you
know i went i put myself on the scale i
gained weight
that means the cortisol is loose because
when you have fear
you produce cortisol and your body can't
break [ __ ] down
i also joined the gym i also got my
bicycle
i also got my punching bag so all these
things
were part of the steps before i could
even get in front of a [ __ ] camera
for you
so what we did was this i'm gonna put up
on my patreon i'm gonna put up
a film a little video of the studio this
is the starter studio today
this is bad bones this is like having a
can
two cans and a [ __ ] string we'll
communicate that's it this is it
you guys want lights and flying saucers
go [ __ ] yourself
go put on nbc this is a podcast
this is me and you against the world
talking that's all this
is so we're going to start back here for
today october 5th
october 7th i'll probably be back here
and then we're going to add things to
it you're going to see the build up of
the podcast just the same way you saw
the church build up
number one you're going to ask we're
going to add some music number two we're
going to add some more lighting
number three then we're going to make
the move to the bar
and you guys are gonna [ __ ] love it
but i'm doing these now
just to let you know uncle joey's here
and we're gonna be fine we're gonna be
fine
everything's beautiful i'm back i'm
naturally
back i'm having a great time with my
family i want to talk to you about
something real quick uh
lee's not going to be on this podcast
and you guys know with all my heart i
love that little [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking
jew
i called him this week for rosh hashanah
he's up there in milwaukee
he's got another month of work at least
32 years old
i remember being 32 years old i remember
being 20 years old
and working for a bookmaker and he paid
me well
and my job was easy and even at 20
i was doing it i did it for maybe nine
months
eight months i was making 140 a day plus
tips whatever
blah blah blah it was a great job but i
always knew in the back of my mind that
what happens when these guys get busted
or when they quit
and i go apply for a job what am i going
to tell them i've been doing for the
last [ __ ] two years
running numbers that's not going to work
that's when i left to colorado when i
was left in april of 83 i left because
not that i was stuck in a job but it was
a job that
was just a job for me i didn't want to
do it forever
you know i felt that lee
wasn't as happy as he was when he first
got on
i mean listen for me to bring leader
this neighborhood this is a family
[ __ ] neighborhood
lee would die aboard me we got deer we
got a couple of raccoons
and that's it there's nothing down here
he'd have to be closer to the city
and the city is a [ __ ] mess right now
believe it or not i care about lee
and believe it or not leaves a mark
they'll chase them and beat that poor
kid up to debt and i didn't want that to
happen
i felt guilty enough leaving dean delray
and other borns of my buddies in l.a i
felt guilty enough
you know but with lee i made sure he
left because i didn't want him staying
in la
steve simone left i still talk to lee
he's still one of my best buddies in the
world
i just thought it was a good time for
lee to move on and i called him a few
weeks ago
he went to see sam tripoli up in uh
madison
and they took a picture and his smile
was [ __ ] amazing and i called him the
next day and i go
where are you i'm in my hotel room
that's when he got stuck in the hotel
room with the stairs so
he didn't leave because he had stairs
the stairs were torching them
the hindus ran and everything it smelled
like curry i loved it they were
torturing them
so uh i told them one day i go hey man
do you have access to that picture and
he looked at it whatever i go look at
your smile on that picture i haven't
seen that smile in a long time
i go you know what the podcast with me
the church
was great for you for a while i thought
lee would come to me one day and say
i need to move on you know i'm going to
start my own podcast i'm going to start
my own network
i'm going to start my whatever but i
didn't he didn't do that
he just worked for me and i i kept
getting guiltier and guiltier
you know he had a couple side jobs what
not but it was basically
sunday and tuesday and then there's five
days that you sit around it's like my
daughter
i can't have lee sitting around for five
days down here there's nothing to do
he'll die down here they ain't nothing
to do i'm barely keeping it together
thank god i smoke weed and i drop an
edible from time to time
i go for a bike ride you know you know
number two i got jimmy florentine
guys let me explain something to you
right now i know you guys are tight with
me i know you guys dig me i need you to
do me a favor
because sometimes in life we we don't
know we just don't know
we don't uh this whole move
like i told brendan schaub on monday
last week on his podcast
this move was eminent for me this was
coming no matter what
whether it was covert or not i was
coming
march 9th march 10th
i was coming here to do nayak march 12th
and then to shoot the movie on the 16th
and 17th
but those other days i was going to meet
with a realtor and we were going to look
at houses in duma
cresco you know canteen act 10 to fly
towards up there uh there's another
place not alpine or not
englewood clips or nothing like that
there was places up there little pockets
that had great schools leonia i'm close
to the bridge
i'm close to the city i'm close to my
friends but not close enough you know
that type of [ __ ] that was all going to
go down march
and then we were coming as a family
april 4th
to buy the house and we're gonna move
that this is
common knowledge me and my wife have
been talking about this for years
my wife had wanted to come here for
years so the move shouldn't have been a
shock to anybody
because we were doing it any way you put
in fact it was going to probably
be we'd buy the house in april spend the
summer in l.a
and then we're going to move like august
15th it was going to be the same result
so a lot of people didn't know that you
think that i was leaving anyway
and i at that time if there wasn't
covered
yeah i might have brought lee if there
wasn't covered and we could still rock
are we closer to the city lee has access
to new york city
he could do his spots but down here i'm
an hour away from the city
he's not gonna do nothing there's no
young kids down here you either go to
high school or you're my [ __ ] age
down here
that's what they have down here they
don't have no bars down here for young
kids they got nothing
so i didn't want to waste any more lease
time we did an eight year run
we did close to 900 [ __ ] episodes we
have
nothing to be embarrassed about we went
out the right way like gentlemen we let
you know
there was no misunderstanding and the
beautiful thing is he's still my [ __ ]
brother
so don't worry about lee's doing great i
miss him and he'll be watching this and
uh eventually we'll zoom him in
on one of the podcasts just to make you
guys feel better
i want to talk to you about something
that's really important here that i've
just figured out
this whole move wouldn't have happened
without jimmy florentine
i don't know if you know who jimmy
florentine is or who isn't
let me tell you what jimmy florentine is
he's a great guy with a great [ __ ]
family
when i tell you if he was running for
president i would vote for him he's that
good of a guy he's opened up
his home and his family to me
i know all his brothers his sisters his
sister-in-law showed me the house
this is a phenomenal guy if you don't
know who jimmy florentine is
or what he's been on or what he's done
or his comedy
do me a favor check him out support him
if he comes to your town i know he's
going to akron next weekend
he's got a couple dates always support
jimmy florentine because when you're
supporting jimmy florentine
rich vaz those guys you're supporting
uncle joey
those guys made it possible for me to
move down here
all i had to do was call jimmy
florentine one time
because once the corona hit
the hot spot was up there so now we were
[ __ ]
we're like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
we can't move into a hot spot in the
middle of a [ __ ]
coronaville so i remembered that i had a
brother who lived down here
and i enjoyed it because he used to sell
fish
and what this [ __ ] would do was
wake up like at four
get to the city like a 4 45 we would go
to a fulton fish
fish market we would get some fish
go get a [ __ ] egg on a [ __ ] roll
we would deliver the fish to
eight or ten restaurants and we'd be
back
down here by one 130. he had a special
shower put in his garage
he would take a shower because he smelt
like fish and i would take a shower
because i smell like fish and then we
jump in the [ __ ] pool
his wife would come out we'd hang out
there and then whatever fish of the day
he put on the grill while we were
while we were swimming the fish would be
cooking
we'd get out we'd [ __ ] eat some fish
we'd hang out
and then at eight o'clock i'd borrow his
car they had a drive through carvel this
is when i was about 380.
i'd drive through carvalho i couldn't
even hold the steering wheel because i
would buy a cone
and a milkshake i'd have to [ __ ]
drive like one of those [ __ ] little
dinosaurs whatever the [ __ ]
you one of those little guys with little
hooks i would just have to
elbow my way out of the driveway eat the
[ __ ] cone
and another drive home i would drink the
milkshake and i'd walk in with the
milkshake and they'd say that's all you
got was a milkshake yeah that's all i
got [ __ ] you
i got a double cone with sprinkles and
whipped cream and [ __ ]
i was busting the calorie meter and
busting the diabetes zone
i've only been to carvel one [ __ ]
time since i've been here even though
lee gave me a 100 gift card because
that's how lee thinks lee thinks i was
gonna go to
carvel every [ __ ] day and be johnny
diabetes what the [ __ ] do you do with a
100 gift card
and carve out beside [ __ ] kill
yourself you know what i'm saying that's
how sweet he is
that's how he's thinking he's like i'm
moving to jersey i'm getting a hundred
dollar carvel car who the [ __ ] gets a
hundred hour carvel
card i got like a 96 dollar balance in
carvel
i took my daughter and me and my wife
split a [ __ ] tone
that's it and that's that but like i was
saying to you
when this happened and i couldn't move
up north
i called jimmy and jimmy was like
i'm on it my sister-in-law is a realtor
i put my wife together with his uh
sister-in-law and the rest is [ __ ]
history
so if you're looking for a house called
trish florentine okay [ __ ] what
do you think you're dealing with
joey [ __ ] bananas i even got realtors
in my [ __ ] world
that's how we're [ __ ] doing it we're
not [ __ ] around here
so i called jimmy florentine
we looked at some houses online me and
my wife
we like this one a friend of mine from
north bergen is an inspector
he came down he did the walkthrough for
me he took a thousand pictures
he wrote what work needed to be done in
the house how we were gonna fix it blah
blah blah blah blah blah
boom we're here how do you like me now
[ __ ]
so this is the studio
for maybe the next two and a half three
weeks and then
we show you the big [ __ ] the bar the
bar is tremendous
we're not gonna do no smoking weed even
though they're gonna vote into the
ballot
i talked to murphy the other day we're
gonna stuff some [ __ ] ballots for the
marijuana thing
you know me dog i'm gonna keep smoking
pot because wherever i'm standing it's
legal that's just the way it is
i got like a three by three cube around
me wherever i'm standing
marijuana is legal a lot of people it's
like it's like being on star trek
when you're with me a blue light comes
right next to you and you could smoke in
that blue light
and nobody will say nothing to you i
don't give a [ __ ] if you're a police
officer and you want to
say something to me if i'm driving i'll
take the [ __ ] punishment
but if i'm just sitting on a corner
walking on foot
smoking a joint on the fresh air of love
and god's love and air
i got it coming to me don't even [ __ ]
say two words to me you got bigger
[ __ ] things to fry you got
there's somebody driving with no
insurance go chase them down you're
going to come bother me because i'm
smoking a [ __ ] joint it's 2020 come
on
give me a [ __ ] break how bored are
you you know what i'm saying
and i support the cops fully i support
what you do i support your work
you know i'm not here to defund the
police you know you
you can't [ __ ] be mad at all of them
because of two bad [ __ ] apples all
right
you know most cops are [ __ ] great i'm
friends with a ton of cops
i get most of my information from cops i
support them in any way they can
you know i'm a felon and when a felon
tells you i support cops what does that
tell you
i support them so go [ __ ] yourself okay
you can't round them all up it's like
anything else
what are you gonna say cuban people are
bad because of tony montana
go [ __ ] yourself they're not bad oh
cubans are bad i know one cuba
joey diaz you want to know cubans are
decent [ __ ] people
i just turned out to be one of the
pieces of [ __ ]
right the same [ __ ] thing we're
talking about here as long as we got
that settled
now you know what i'm talking about i
ain't mad at nobody i'm happy with
everybody
the stress levels are down and guess
what i'm ready to [ __ ] take over
like i'm ready i'm ready to get my peace
i'm not looking to be dave chappelle or
kevin hart or joe rogan i never was
i just wanted a little piece of the
[ __ ] pie
just to let me know that i was on the
right track that my work
did something it did [ __ ] something
look at the background you got def
leopard
high and dry one of my favorite albums
you got led zeppelin too
the album that started for me i'm going
to get into that later about the
album of the week but led zeppelin too
the first time i heard larry's zap on
tour made me smoke weed so i had to put
it up behind me
a game of death is behind me the last
bruce lee picture this is a poster given
to me
by uh mr alvarado whatever is [ __ ]
now i can't think of his name
[ __ ] great kid i'm too [ __ ] stoned
i don't know what happened
and over here i got [ __ ] ac dc
bonfire what are you [ __ ] nuts a
little something for dean delray out of
respect
i miss dean with all my heart i know you
guys are still supporting them on
patreon and whatnot
i miss that dude we talk every day i
know he did a gig at an amphitheater the
other night and whatnot
and that's it and that's that this is
gonna be the simple [ __ ] studio but
the next time
you come on the podcast there'll be
something else
then the next time there'll be music
then the next time they'll be [ __ ]
every time we're gonna get stronger for
you okay
i just wanted you guys to understand
where i'm at
i want to close your one thing though
that i realized
that i didn't know i had no [ __ ] idea
and i might as well talk to you about it
right now
[ __ ] because it's monday this is
what we do on a monday morning
what i want to talk to you was i feel
like i lied to you people
i've been thinking about this for the
last two weeks because i didn't know it
i feel like i lied to you people over
the last
well i started moving i started finding
[ __ ]
and i started reading creepy [ __ ] and i
started ripping up a lot of [ __ ]
and if i could have burnt it on fire i
would have burnt it on fire
i found those old notebooks all the
notebooks i had
when i started from 91 i collected those
notebooks
and all those notebooks got taken away
when my apartment got towed
when i had that apartment look at the
car that i lived in on ralphie's block
and they told my headshots they told all
my [ __ ]
vhs's they took all my clothes i mean
they took everything so all those
notebooks were gone
but what i did find
i got some [ __ ] to show you
[ __ ] in this move
i found like uh the box of my old coach
old call sheets i have a call sheet
to every project i ever worked on
what's a call sheet joey it's like your
name with who you're working with
what scenes you're doing who the
director is
what time you're starting what the
temperature is going to be for the day
what the high and low is
what time the [ __ ] thing ends you
know the three scenes it's call sheets
i found a [ __ ] envelope of all my
[ __ ] call sheets
from marin to [ __ ] the longest shot
i did i don't know how many days on the
longest shirt i found all the [ __ ]
call sheets
i found the call sheets for the first
job i ever booked 19 wheels of justice
i found [ __ ] you wouldn't imagine but i
also found old notebooks
old notebooks that went back to 99.
and i got to tell you something i read
through my old goals
and through my old [ __ ] like what i
wanted at that time
dog some of this [ __ ] was creepy i mean
i had to like [ __ ] look at it and go
this is when i was getting high and i
would write those journals
holy [ __ ] i started reading some of
those [ __ ] journals
and my heart broke i mean towards the
end of me getting high
it seemed like i just wanted to [ __ ]
die
it seemed like what i was reading
was [ __ ] scary
as [ __ ] you know and i thought about
those uh we did these series with joe
rogan
red band has them i think red band has
even posted up we've discussed this
before
in like 2006 or seven on like a [ __ ]
coke bender mixed with [ __ ] vicodin
and alcohol
i did a show with joe at the uh house of
blues
we did like two nights and i disappeared
after the first night
and the second night we did it and i
i just was i was uh
the day after you get high you know you
have no
[ __ ] chemicals and they have no
serotonin you're not happy
you just you've used up everything like
you just killed it
i was numb i remember going on stage and
getting off and them asking me like
what's the problem
and me telling them like i i was just
sick and tired of [ __ ] this life
i really was in 2006 i was sick and
tired of this [ __ ]
not not comedy and not my life but that
i couldn't get away from the cocaine
but you had to read the [ __ ] i was
writing in 99 about it
like i had the notebooks i cried
i [ __ ] cried i couldn't believe that
that's where my mind was at
and i kept reading and i kept it and i
this [ __ ] got intriguing
like this [ __ ] got interesting like i
didn't i didn't want nobody to get their
hands on this [ __ ]
i started reading this thing like a
[ __ ] hitchcock novel
i just could not let it go because i
could not believe
that i was in that bad shape
and mentally emotionally i mean the only
thing that was keeping me abroad
was stand up and then i read the
notebooks after i met my wife
and you know
i had respect for her i could read and
the things that i liked her you know
thank god
i had a like i mean she was my
girlfriend but
i could see me the writing of me
from liking her to falling in love with
her
that's pretty [ __ ] amazing like i saw
the writing cross over
then there was a big gap in notebooks
like for some reason
there was like two notebooks that were
missing and i
picked up again when the cocaine when i
was free from the cocaine
that's why i tell you guys you got to
write those journals and when you're
finished just put them in a draw
and just keep writing and put them in
the drawing put them in a drawer and put
them in a drawer
and then when you have a time put them
in a box and put like a note of what
years these work
if i could do it all over again i would
do it that much better i did the best i
could
for what i knew but now at 57 guys you
got to keep a journal
you got to keep a journal to see where
your heart
is on a daily basis and why you feel
that way i'm telling you
it's like documenting everything i read
[ __ ]
that made me [ __ ] cringe of what i
was thinking
i was not right in the [ __ ] head but
when you read the
paperwork from 2006
the journal from 2007 when you read the
journals from 2009
it's like a different [ __ ] person you
could see the influence
the drugs had over my mind my creativity
everything that surrounded me drugs were
a major part
it's a [ __ ] nightmare to read but the
truth that i wanted to come to you with
something i found out
in those [ __ ] i've told you
guys for years
when i got into comedy it wasn't to be
dave chappelle it wasn't to be richard
pryor or lenny
bruce or any clark for that matter i
just wanted to get saved
i just i wanted to be a human being
i just want to be i didn't want to be a
mayor
i didn't want to be a president i don't
even want to be a people looked up to
i just want to be normal i just didn't
want to steal i didn't want to [ __ ]
do drugs is that too much to ask
i just i just wanted a job i didn't want
to be rich
i didn't care about boats i didn't care
about nothing
i just wanted to function like a human
being without [ __ ] drugs
the reefer please the reef is kid stuff
that that that doesn't affect you at all
if it does
it affects some people from time to time
you got to give it a breather even i get
a beer from time to time
some days i don't know when the last
time i took an edible wash i had a
monday
monday i took an edible oh my god i was
[ __ ] up
i took uh uh little florentine's
son his sister my wife and my daughter
and we all went out to eat because jim
florentine has a son
and he's a little older than my daughter
but they get along he's got the patience
of the saint
so we all went out to eat and i took the
edibles like at thought i was a little
bored
it was monday i had done everything i
had to do i worked out
something else happened monday something
happened
oh not the compressor guy somebody else
was supposed to come
oh that was always a jewish holiday so
mercy was home so threw my [ __ ] day
off
so that's what it was my day was thrown
off completely
i couldn't do what i had to do and i
looked in the drawer depth
and i saw there was some [ __ ]
old-school edibles in there i had
a mix because i brought a few different
types from la with me
the number one ones on the [ __ ] the
atx those 200 milligrams those orange
scary things
they're [ __ ] scary i didn't even take
one of those
i'd even take one of those i took the
ones from the whatever labs
that i have that did 25 milligrams each
but they put something else in them i
don't know what they put in them but
they put something else on them i'm
telling you right now
uncle joey knows when somebody puts
something in those [ __ ]
and now they got a hashtag so what did i
do
i [ __ ] took four hashtags off the bat
i put the video up you guys saw it
i put four hashtags off the back then
after the video turned off
i decided to eat two more because you
know i'm a [ __ ] gavon
and it didn't stop there they sent me a
little chocolate bar
i don't know how many milligrams it was
it didn't matter at that point
i ate that too next thing you know i'm
[ __ ] falling asleep everywhere
i am [ __ ] nodding like a junkie
i do not remember the diner i don't
remember
eating i don't remember what the [ __ ] i
ate
all i remember is when i went to weigh
myself in on thursday the dude told me
you gained weight what the [ __ ] happened
i go i have no idea
and then yesterday when i two days ago
when i went to
jimmy florentine's son's game he's like
uncle joey those disco fries were great
i go what disco fries
he goes the ones we ate on monday they
were the best disco fries i ever had i
go
we had disco fries no wonder i [ __ ]
gained weight
jesus [ __ ] christ disco fries and
what they give you
with a cheeseburger deluxe okay let me
tell you something
there's other reasons but i love new
jersey
they have a thing called the
cheeseburger deluxe i have not got
gotten to get it yet
i have been to a diner i go get
breakfast at a diner
nice diners here real close to the house
my daughter loves him my wife loves them
i have not but in the old days if you
got a cheeseburger deluxe it was a
cheeseburger
with steak fries not those little
california hiv fries they give you
i don't like those skinny fries take
those and shove them up your ass
if you're gonna give me a fry give me a
[ __ ] fry not that i need to eat a fry
i'm just telling you right now
in the old days i don't need to eat
fries right now but i did eat them the
other day
so you take [ __ ] you take fries
you put mozzarella cheese on it you melt
it and then you put [ __ ] gravy on it
that's a disco fry do you understand me
you have no [ __ ] idea
how good those things were so when the
weight just came to the table
they're like i'll take a cheeseburger i
go two orders of disco fries for the
table
because the kids were there i knew they
would lose their mind my daughter lost a
[ __ ] mind
do you understand my daughter has
stopped using ketchup
that's an insult to california that's
how bad the food was
in california that my daughter hasn't
even used ketchup
since we moved to jersey she's like the
food tastes like something and daddy
that's right
we're in [ __ ] jersey even i tasted a
baked potato last night my wife made a
baked potato she bought
it shoprite i even asked i go is it me
or is this [ __ ] potato taste better
the potato is delicious i only ate a
half of baked potato the points the
weight watching points
it's five you eat half it's two and a
half
give it three [ __ ] it what do you know
maybe you hit a [ __ ] mint throughout
the day or something you got an extra
point there
but i got that [ __ ] up my wife said
something to me she goes
you know you were [ __ ] hammered then
we came home from the diner
and i sat on the chair in the living
room and just passed out
i woke up like a two everybody was gone
there were one minute i was watching
cartoons
with my daughter and then everybody was
gone and the next morning after
breakfast my wife said to me
what happened to you last night i don't
know i ate four of those things
maybe six maybe eight i don't [ __ ]
know
because once i eat them in the afternoon
i'm a ghana because i'll keep popping
them
i forget that i popped them and i'll pop
everything i'll pop one of those i'll
pop a high blood pressure pill
because i'll start thinking that i take
my blood pressure medication and i take
more and then i'm walking around all
[ __ ] up all afternoon
i got problems i'm here i'm the person
to admit it
that i got [ __ ] problems don't even
let me tell you about meeting the viking
by mistaking going on the bike ride i
never even told you that one yet during
the pandemic
i had a thousand accidents i melted the
tea
kettle at the [ __ ] corporate housing
because i got so high
and i couldn't hear the tea kettle going
off without my hearing aids i got
stories [ __ ]
but we're gonna wait and give you those
later these are the stories
of the corona [ __ ] pandemic the
things i went through you know how many
nights i got up the first two weeks of
the pandemic
i must have gained [ __ ] 20 pounds
i was up i don't even want to tell you
how much weight i gained the first month
after the pandemic
because all i was doing was eating
edibles and [ __ ] eating
then we started working out then the
anxiety went down i started riding my
bicycle
and we got the weight back to normal but
i've had [ __ ]
adventures during this pandemic every
time my wife goes to bed at 9
30 you might as well raise the insurance
on the house you don't know if i'm gonna
burn it down dog
i melted the tea kettle do you
understand me i was so high
i [ __ ] was watching tv and i couldn't
i was making tea to relax
and i couldn't hear the [ __ ] when i went
back there the thing was twisted
it collapsed on top of itself the
whistle wasn't even working
it was going like it was it was [ __ ]
up
i poured the tea i didn't say no no
buddy i had to pick it up with a [ __ ]
towel it was so hot
the next morning my wife came out saying
what the [ __ ] happened to the tea cat
kettle i don't know i couldn't [ __ ]
hear it so now if i make tea
i stand there like a soldier because i
don't want to burn my house down
i got to stand there for 10 minutes and
wait till the whistle goes off like the
[ __ ] that i am
i got problems what are you gonna do
you're gonna smoke grief you gotta
hydrate [ __ ] anyway
so what story i want to tell you that
was a lie was
i didn't i didn't say it as a as a
a lie i just didn't even know
when i got into this thing i got into
this thing
to be exactly where i am today i didn't
get into this thing
because i wanted to drive a maserati i
didn't get into this thing
because i wanted to be a movie star i
didn't get into this thing
because none of those reasons i got into
this thing
to be somebody to make my friends proud
of me
these friends that i've been seeing
lately that i go to lunches with
or dinner with from time to time listen
the page has been flipped one of the
reasons why i didn't want to move to
color
to new jersey was because the truth was
finally going to be told
you know i did some [ __ ] up things
when i was a kid here
i don't expect a [ __ ] parade i don't
expect a parade
i do expect some people to actually wait
for an apology
i've apologized to as many people as i
can
i've sent cards to as many people as i
can
but i know me coming here for a weekend
and me living here is two different
stories
you know so i'm i've been hearing a
couple things lately blah blah
so i keep my things light but the truth
of the matter is
i wanted to be in this position what
position is that
a position where i can make the friends
that i do have the friends that i go to
dinner with and whatnot
when we're reading and somebody comes to
the table and they said hey i like you
on the rogan podcast
or i like you on marin or whatever
i look at my friends and their [ __ ]
faces light up
and that means more to me remember these
were my friends
when i was robbing people they didn't
become my friends
after i got a netflix special or after i
had a podcast or after i was on joe
rogan special
these guys were my friends when i was
straight up robbing people
and they knew it but they knew where my
heart was they knew what my past had
been
and they knew i was a little [ __ ] up
but they let that slide
they knew what my heart was and now
today they see me they see me with a
daughter
they see me with a wife they say i'm not
doing drugs
you know they see that i'm [ __ ] doing
something with my life and they see that
i did something with my life
you know tuesday i went up to my mom's
grave
the [ __ ] flower shop was closed sure
9
30 they went on vacation 9 30. that's
the day
so whenever that was wednesday i went up
there the [ __ ] flower shop was closed
i ended up going to my buddy's house uh
my buddy's funeral parlor
and hanging out with him yeah my buddy
has a funeral vault
and i grew up with him and i went over
there and sat with him for two hours and
talked
with another friend of mine that i grew
up with and then i went
i was gonna go get cuban food but there
was too much [ __ ] traffic
so i said [ __ ] it i made it right and i
went to this little restaurant from
spain
and i was sitting there and just a
friend of mine called me out of the blue
i called a couple of friends
one friend was on vacation i couldn't
get a hold of him
and a friend of mine called and i said
i'm over here come over and
join me you know i hadn't seen him he
came over and sat with me
and all of a sudden we ate and while we
were eating i asked the waiter for the
bill
and the way it goes it's been taken care
of
and i go there's nobody here who the
[ __ ] are they taking care of it
and he goes to jonah did and i looked at
the owner and
i left a nice tip and i went over and i
shook the but
that's not the moral of the story the
moral of stories you should have seen my
friends
he couldn't believe it he's like who
bought you [ __ ] dinner i go i don't
know
and and when i when i went over and
shook the owner's hand i came back
my buddy had a smile from ear to [ __ ]
ear
like this is one of my friends that we
used to drive into the city with
and do some crazy [ __ ] with when we were
sitting there when i went back and sat
down at the table
he had a grin from ear to ear he was
happy
i could tell he was so [ __ ] proud
so right then is where i noticed that
i got into this to make my friends proud
i wanted to do something with my life so
yeah i never thought i would be an ex i
would even be an extra
or any of that [ __ ] but you know what at
the end i made it to where i am
and my dave chappelle not really and my
[ __ ]
uh my man bill burke not really
i'm joey [ __ ] diaz i don't know how i
got here
i got here through hard work minding my
business
sticking my [ __ ] nose to the [ __ ]
grind and doing spots and writing and
never giving up
no matter what i read in those [ __ ]
pages i never gave up no matter what i
felt
i never gave up and that's why we're
here
and this is why we do the [ __ ]
podcast so i want to apologize to you
guys for saying that
when i got into this i just wanted to be
normal no
i wanted to do something with my life
because i had to prove to my friends
that what they did for me
wasn't in vain they did something for me
i wanted to prove to them
that they had made the right shape they
made all mistakes in their life that's
fine
but they made the right choice by
friending me that means the world to me
and me doing what i'm doing today
means the world to them that they were a
part of it
and that's it and that's that this has
been uncle joey's joint for this week
october 5th 2020 the pandemic is still
on
but they can't stop us you understand me
we're gonna be keep doing these
i don't know if it's monday and
wednesday i don't know if it's tuesday
thursday i know what it is
and you don't know what it is we're just
gonna show up on your [ __ ] screen
and you're gonna watch and you're gonna
enjoy and you're gonna have a good time
and that's it that's that will we have
guests yes we'll have guests
well we have videos yes we'll have
videos where we have explosions and fire
something's gonna happen you know what
i'm saying something will happen we'll
get the chick to come down and finally
fought in lee's face
we'll do some type of live podcast for
you guys some christmas extravaganza
i'm just playing it with the pandemic i
don't want to overstep my boundaries
i know you guys got your schedules and
your lives i'm just here to give you a
little bit of [ __ ]
you know one hour to maybe relax listen
to me get your head together
say to yourself hey i thought i had a
bad this [ __ ] guy's really [ __ ]
you know
just whatever you want this is what this
hour's for
again you go to patreon.com joeydears
if you want more videos or more content
this
podcast uncle joey's joint is free it'll
always be free
and it'll always come at you at youtube
do not forget
this wednesday the 7th of october 8
o'clock
uncle vinnie's the 14th the 21st and the
28th
all wednesdays 38 tickets 20 hours to
get in
working out with uncle joey nice and
easy
no [ __ ] drama okay number one i want
to thank my sponsors
all of them they all stuck around i
don't know what the [ __ ] people are
talking about
manscaped draftkings the [ __ ]
hard on people everybody stuck around so
i don't know what the [ __ ]
i was reading online the other day some
people that he had no sponsor i don't
know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about today's show is sponsored
by
my [ __ ] family okay my peeps in day
one
[ __ ] on it baby right here
alpha [ __ ] brain mushrooms nootropics
whatever the [ __ ] they call it
this is what got me through eating one
of these
started me going through once i got the
[ __ ] corporate housing
i started with these but my sleeping was
off
i'm going to bed at 2 o'clock now 2 3
o'clock in the morning because i'm used
to california time
i had to cut it back oh i got to spray
one of these
just for lee just to make sure he's not
in the area to clean
off the speed those mallows you know
what i'm saying you always gotta think
ali
anyway so i was having a hard time
sleeping
i started taking new moods it helped it
was really good
then i got sent to melatonin these two
together
forget about it you're sleeping and
[ __ ] 10 minutes you understand me
what i'm trying to say to you is i've
been went on it since day one
and i'm still [ __ ] on it and there's
a reason for that
it's quality customer service and their
products are [ __ ] tremendous
go to honor.com right now look at the
fine line or something and say god
you got a problem preston church
c-h-u-r-c-h
i'm gonna give you ten percent off okay
first meet
that's how we start off so go to
honor.com right now all right
and start with that number two the
church is also brought to you by you
ready for this one [ __ ]
cbd lion with a [ __ ] calendar
what are you [ __ ] nuts they got
everything in here with what they have
me i stick to the simple stuff i like
their gummy bears
i like that [ __ ] cream the vapor pad
look at this
they got cbd [ __ ] patches
do you understand me you know what this
is you look at me going joey what's this
this is a cbd patch you [ __ ] suckers
you open this up you take this out
look at that it's a cbd
patch i've been telling you my shoulders
are [ __ ] up right
all right your shoulders are [ __ ] up
all right no problem i got no nails so
you take this off here
put this on here
48 hours 48 hours
of cbd slowly going into your joints
whether it's your knee
your hips your shoulders i put one on my
dick it almost exploded
just just kidding just [ __ ] around
with you but that's
the technology of cbd lion go to
cbdline.com right now
look at that third-party lab results and
then get back to me
i don't want you buying cbd off the
street or some [ __ ]
these people this is their life this
their business is what they do
and they're the best who else would send
you a catalog
like this they care they give a [ __ ]
read read about cbn cbds
and how they affect you but for right
now go to cbdlion.com right now
and press in church and get 10 percent
off your order delivered right to your
[ __ ] house
i want to thank annette i want to thank
the church i want to thank one by one
podcast
and i want to thank you guys for [ __ ]
sitting there saying joy when are you
going to come with something for free
i'm paying over that patreon you got to
give me something for free
there you go you got the podcast of the
week we're gonna come at you twice a
week
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart thank you very much for being a
part of it
and stay black we'll see you in a few
days
you